jetzt schauen wir aber auf skandale und
klingel 1 und die nicht bei den royals
in der adels welt nein in den
spitzenpositionen der öffentlich
rechtlichen sendeanstalten die nehmen
nämlich nicht ab grund genug der feinen
intendanten gesellschaft war ganz genau
auf die finger zu schauen und sie werden
nicht glauben was da so alles auf dem
konto landet wie viel sie verdienen
längst hat sich eine riesen debatte um
die gehälter der intendanten von ard und
zdf zusammen gebraut seit dem skandal
rauswurf von rbb chefin patricia
schlesinger diskutiert deutschland über
den umgang mit unseren gebührengeldern
die herrschaften intendanten verdienen
nämlich ganz schön viel spitzenreiter
ist wdr chef tom buhrow mit stolzen
413.000 euro jahresgehalt dicht gefolgt
von norbert himmler vom zdf mit
372.000 euro zum vergleich der
bundeskanzler bezieht gerade einmal
362.000 euro
unmöglich findet auch finanzminister
christian lindner und fordert her mit
dem freiwilligen gehälter deckel für das
öffentlich-rechtliche
spitzenpersonal an der spitze der
öffentlich-rechtlichen wird teilweise
enorm verdient sagt lindner zur bild am
sonntag ich bin gegen jede neiddebatte
aber kein intendant sollte mehr
verdienen als der bundeskanzler
hier ist eine selbstverpflichtung nötig
um mit dem geld der gebührenzahler
sparsam umzugehen und nicht nur der
verdienst der damen und herren
senderchefs ist üppig auch die rente
unserer tv administratoren schlägt dem
fass den boden aus so bezieht der ex ndr
intendant lutz marmor derzeit satte
20.000 euro betriebs rente monatlich
wenn wdr chef tom buhrow im sommer 2025
in rente gehen wird kann er sich sogar
über bis zu 25.000 euro im monat freuen
die gesetzliche rente kommt ganz
nebenbei bemerkt noch mal drauf laut der
kommission zur ermittlung des
finanzbedarfs der anstalten müssen die
öffentlich-rechtlichen aktuell
537 millionen euro pro jahr in die
altersversorgung pumpen auch hier regt
sich jetzt widerstand
die cdu verlangt öffentlich einen harten
schnitt sie beschloss beim parteitag
dass die gehälter und pensionen bei ard
und zdf künftig nicht höher als im
öffentlichen dienst ausfallen sollen
dann wäre ein intendanten gehalt
generell bei rund 15.000 euro gedeckelt
und die gesamt rente die höher als
10.000 815 euro zum vergleich ein
normaler deutscher rentner erhält
derzeit in allerbesten fall monatlich
2009 161 euro gesetzliche
altersversorgung
prunk und protz bei den
öffentlich-rechtlichen und das alles auf
kosten der steuerzahler einfach
skandalös
[Musik]